joining me now is missouri senator josh
hawley senator thank you so much for
being here this evening
so does joe biden in his administration
do they have it right or could they use
a refresher on i don't know
constitutional law one-on-one
well i thought the fact that uh the
president referred to the second
amendment as a
phony argument i believe were his words
pete just shows you that in his mind the
second amendment's a phony amendment i
mean he doesn't believe it's actually in
the constitution he clearly does not
believe
in the right to keep and bear arms what
boggles my mind is
these liberals seem fine with criminals
out on the streets having all the
firearms they want they're fine with
rioting they're fine with violence so
long as it's done by
criminals but when law-abiding citizens
want to own a firearm legally
as the second amendment guarantees then
they completely lose their minds and
that's what
biden is proposing to crack down on now
these are these are law abiding citizens
whose rights he wants to take away the
criminals you know go and do whatever
you want but
abiding citizens they're the ones it's
exactly backwards
it is always exactly backwards for the
left they never get the
the basic equation equation you just
laid out but here's another angle joe
biden he tried to make it sound like
his gun grab will solve all of america's
problems listen to this
today we're taking steps to confront not
just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis for a fraction of the cost
of gun violence we can save lives
create safe and healthy communities and
build economies that work for all of us
senator this must feel like deja vu for
you so it's a coveted bill that's not
really about cove but it's an
infrastructure that's built it's not
really about infrastructure and now it's
a gun bill that's about
a public health crisis or safe and
healthy community
help me out what are they really trying
to do
well this is really about confiscating
weapons i mean this is what the left has
wanted to do for a long time this is
what
half the presidential candidates or more
on the democrat side ran on
just a year ago in their primaries and
at the end of the day the only way to
make work what biden and the others want
to do and the legislation they propose
is to have a national gun registry
and ultimately to take away firearms
from law-abiding citizens that is where
this is headed that's what many of them
have been open many democrats have been
open about wanting to do
his anti-gun activist who he's trying to
put at the atf that's what
that's what he wants to do so this is
where it's headed
and can i just by the way say that this
idea
that that somehow cracking down on the
second amendment is going to help
revitalize economic prospects for the
working class
this from joe biden the guy who has
presided over millions of jobs going to
china
who has thought that that's a great deal
whose economic policies and the obama
biden administration
hollowed out the working class and now
he says if i take away your right to
bear arms that that'll be good for you
economically i mean it's just
this is insanity well in addition to
taking away your pipelines i'm going to
take away your pistols too it'll all go
well for you
don't worry about that it's all good
senator i got to ask you because you've
talked a lot about what's happened down
in georgia the way in which
major league baseball and other work
corporations have rallied
uh behind the sort of calls of racism
jim crow 2.0 from joe biden
you called for them to be busted up what
needs to happen when it comes to
election integrity
and the way in which big corporations
are ganging up to get their way
well you know what's happening in
georgia is what they tried to do for
those of us who stood up for election
integrity back in january
anyone who has said that our elections
need to be free they need to be fair we
need to consider election reform
they try to cancel you and now the
corporations are trying to do the same
thing to georgia and they're going to
try to do it
to anybody any state any person who
stands up for election integrity and
when it comes to these corporations
they've gotten big
and powerful because government has
helped them government has subsidized
them and government has looked the other
way
and it's time to bust them up i mean
listen republicans used to be the party
of trust busting we believe
in free competition we believe in robust
competition we don't believe in
protecting monopolies
and we certainly don't believe in a
bunch of corporatists running this
country
and that's what these corporations want
they want to run the country tell you
what to think
tell you what to do we can't allow that
man absolute unchecked power and for too
long as you pointed out
better than anybody uh it's been the
republican party that's been complacent
when it comes to corporations because we
thought they were our friend and it
turns out the boardrooms
have a quite different view senator josh
hawley thank you so much appreciate your
time tonight
thank you